this guerilla marketing campaign video
for a new product comes to us from
Sweden
I hate to say it but it was actually
quite fun to watch these people get into
the news quite silly bicycle accidents
but then be safe because they have this
perfectly great helmet that saves them
every time yes this is the invisible
bike helmet so we traveled to Sweden to
meet its inventors and on Theresa and
ask them what's wrong with traditional
helmets we went out in the city asking
people with the questionnaire why they
didn't use bicycle helmets and what they
wanted in order to start using them and
they asked for something invisible that
didn't destroy their hair so we
understood that it has to be something
radical this is the bike helmet I've
been waiting for having the hair that I
have it's always been a little bit of a
problem it's keeping people far from
protecting themselves it's it's an issue
how do you make a cool-looking helmet
well let's get rid of the element it's
pretty smart and on Therese undertook
numerous tests to protect their helmet
so how does it work to sense if you're
in a crash situation there are two micro
sensors in there an accelerometer and a
gyro and between the two of them that
can give you a fairly good idea of the
position and the acceleration that the
caller's going through and then of
course what the human is going through
so the data from the accelerometer and
the gyroscope go to a microprocessor
which has to make the decision of
whether or not you're actually in an
accident they didn't say to perform
thousands of test cases of accidents but
they took that data and said this is an
accident and the processor inside of
here is able to compare your real-time
situation to all that data and then know
if you're actually getting in an
accident or not now if the
microprocessor determines that yes
indeed an accident has happened what
it'll do is it'll trigger the release of
helium gas from a compressed gas
canister in the neck of the device and
this will cause the inflatable helmet to
be filled with helium gas in half a
second
people in a big industry and told us
that what we were trying to do was
impossible and it was a great feeling to
prove them wrong
seven years later we asked him to
simulate a bicycle accident all right
here we go okay that didn't work
a bit